The fastest population rises are in Africa or in Asia,...
...which will have 8 of the 10 most populous countries by 2050.
India is set to overtake China as the country with the largest population.
Nigeria has one of the fastest growing populations in the world.
It's set to become the world's third most populous country.
Populations are also rising because they are aging.
Fewer people are dying than are being born.
In the last century, life expectancy has almost doubled in some countries.
In India, it's almost tripled.
However, in some parts of the world, populations are decreasing.
Japan's population of 127 million...
...is forecast to shrink by about one-third in the next 50 years.
But the top 10 countries with the fastest shrinking populations,...
...are all in Eastern Europe.
These countries suffer from the combined effect of low birth rate,...
...a relatively high mortality rate and massive out-migration.